a front row seat at the platinum jubilee
will cost you a sturdy tent some bunting
and a lot of patience especially as it
doesn't start for another two days
this is dedication no this is love
royal superfan mary jane has plenty of
it she came up from cornwall to secure
her spot and says this 70-year
anniversary is not to be missed
she served us she's given her life to us
for 70 years this is thank you
donna agrees this will be worth the
journey from connecticut her dedication
to the monarchy has gained her fans of
her own as someone who's been to every
royal occasion she's come prepared i
brought the tent i bought a camp chair i
brought space blankets some sleeping bag
air mattresses tarps you know winter
coat boots you know
hat gloves mittens you
know it works
from cornwall to connecticut and canada
their commitment can't be faulted the
respect for the royal family has gone
generationally so it started with her
grandmother to hurt her kids and my
daughter has two corgis named marco and
middleton
shielded from their view for now are the
final preparations for saturday's party
in the palace which promises to be a
star-studded affair
earlier the queen's gold state coach not
seen in public for 20 years paraded
through westminster in a final rehearsal
for sunday's pageant
marching alongside it service personnel
from the armed forces carefully
preparing for a procession steeped in
rich tradition and history
if you're a tourist in london at the
moment hoping to catch a glimpse of
buckingham palace then this is just
about as close as you're going to get
because much of the surrounding areas
have already been cordoned off but the
sense of anticipation is building
pageant and parade rehearsals and
soundcheck at the concert stage behind
me and jubilee themed food and drink
flying off supermarket shelves
as for the person at the center of it
all the queen is now back at windsor
castle after spending a few days resting
at balmoral she'll soon make her way to
the palace along with thousands of
others who are expected to line the
streets leading up to the royal
residence
some are more prepared than others for
this one-of-a-kind celebration all they
need to do now is stay dry
ashnaharanag skynys in central london